foreign
got another one for you
already there's no limit to these you
must know that by now I'm good for that
I'm glad there's no limit I like them
okay so this one is we've we've heard
this people have talked about it and
thought about it what happens when you
jump in an airplane
uh well hopefully you're going somewhere
I I don't know what do you mean what
happens when you jump in it you're
playing flying you know you mean what
happens when you literally jump in it
yeah I thought you were like yeah jump
in the airplane I'm going here you know
oh jump onto an airplane no you're in
the airplane in the aisle and then you
jump
okay okay you go up and down some people
thing that the airplane's going 500
miles an hour right if you jump you end
up pinned against the back wall they
watch too many Warner Brothers cartoon
that's what's wrong with those people
okay so why you're using the cartoon
laws of physics instead of the actual
laws of physics yeah in that person's
world you know what else happens
um if you you know that you're not
standing on the edge of a cliff you can
actually stand on things gravity only
kicks in with your awareness where
that's it you know and it's a new law of
physics right there right plus if you're
hitting the head with a frying pan your
face takes the shape of the phone that's
right you just become two big eyes with
a round face that's right yes
cartoon laws are physics cartoon laws of
physics so what I my answer here might
be obvious but I know there are people
out there who wondered whether the plane
would just sort of escape from under
your feet for how fast it's moving okay
so this is a very basic sort of first
week of physics that you learn this and
you see demonstrations of it but I will
now tell you okay okay when the plane
takes off
and it is cruising at some constant
speed
pick any speed 563 miles per hour fine
if it's constant
the plane is moving 563 miles an hour
and so are you
and so is the air
inside the plane
so is the fly that happened to fly into
the plane before they closed the door
you the air the fly of moving 563 miles
per hour if you're all moving at the
same speed together
then you don't know how fast you're
moving yeah you're not moving at all you
know I'm basically in the moving
reference frame of the plane you're not
moving at all correct
so if you jump up you will land right
back where you started right it's that
simple let me get a brown number let's
say you're going 600 miles an hour okay
but 600 miles an hour is 10 miles per
minute
that's a mile every six seconds I'm
right okay and in New York City there's
20 blocks per mile so that's by like
three blocks per second
okay oh man can we can we find that
Transportation 63 bucks per second I
gotta get around Manhattan the way I'd
like to man that'd be fantastic that
would be a flying car maybe you would do
that okay so now watch so if you jump up
and stay in the plane that's going 600
miles an hour you stay airborne for one
second right
and then you land where you started
you also move forward three blocks three
blocks
so if someone is outside of the plane
and watched you you would jump up and
you would follow this Arc
right a parabolic Arc in my reference
frame because I'm outside of the plane I
see you jumped and land and there's a
beautiful parabolic Arc that you took
right you also get a gold medal when you
land the long jump
so another way to do this is and we you
we do this in physics class if you have
a train like a model train because this
is a great physics demo and the the
smokestack of the train has a little uh
spring you can put a ping pong ball in
it just a tiny ball there it is as the
train is moving the spring can pop the
golf ball straight up okay and then
where does the golf ball land does the
train leave it behind no because the
golf ball had the same forward motion as
the train did all the train did was give
it upwards motion like you jumping in
the airplane right then it fell back
down so it'll shoot it up and it'll fall
back down and land exactly back in the
nozzle
and you will see it take that Arc and
land where it had taken off and that is
the train and golf ball version of you
jumping inside of an airplane as far as
you're concerned you're Landing in the
same spot but as far as I'm concerned
you're not right you're three blocks
farther down down the road
cool so it's it's it has to do with your
reference frame and it's a remarkable
thing if if the vessel is big enough so
you don't feel jiggles
you don't know how fast the thing is
going we're on Earth
Earth is going eight uh 18 miles per
second around the Sun yeah
wow okay now you if you want to land in
a different place
do that while the plane is accelerating
right okay now the flight attendants
won't let you do this but yeah right
when the plane touches down killjoys
they are I'm trying to do a physics
experiment here what do you mean I gotta
sit down and pass it my seatbelt and put
my and why is what is it with the seat
in the upright position the seat only
goes back two and a half inches please
please put your seat up sir sir please
could you see that oh sorry let me put
my seat up okay there you go yeah
because now you'll survive the crash
before you wouldn't have right oh thank
you for saving my life with this two and
a half inch differential
so actually I think I know why they do
that really why yeah you want you want
to know why I would like to know okay
that when all the seats are aligned if
you're climbing to get out
in a wreckage then you don't have to
navigate differently oriented seats
yeah
that makes sense I'm pretty sure that's
how that how that rolls okay so
if you magically got permission to do a
physics experiment the moment the wheels
touched okay because what happens the
moment the wheels touch on a run on a
Runway they put the engines into reverse
thrust okay and so now the engine
exhaust reverses
that is pointing forward instead of
backwards and if they if necessary
they'll also apply their brakes
so they might be landing at 200 miles an
hour and it's ultimately zero
okay okay if you jump while that's
happening you will not land in the same
spot
because when you jump the plane was
going 200 miles an hour but when you
landed the plane was going 180 miles an
hour you jump again and so you have a
faster speed going forward than the
plane does because the plane is slowing
down
so you could just jump up and down while
the plane is on the runway and
ultimately end up in the cockpit nice
well just just by jumping straight up
and down yeah but the door will be
locked because you know security reasons
yeah they'll shoot you if you yeah
so consider
that's why
they're animate about your seatbelt on
takeoff and Landing but not when you're
cruising
because the acceleration and the
deceleration is what changes your
relationship to the fuselage if you jump
up and for and come back down again
right okay so yeah that's why they can
go 500 miles an hour you may now remove
your seat belts and walk around the
cabin but it's just pulling in to the to
the to the gate
right it's going five miles an hour but
then it's going zero okay
that's enough to knock you over
look at that so that that's all I gotta
say about jumping up and down in the
damn airplane that's cool well I mean uh
now when uh you hear that I have been
arrested
tell them it's a science
I'm just letting everybody know that
this was a science experience I did it
for science people take it we'll get it
Go fund me to to get you out of my bail
that's right get my bail money up people
because we got that we know what we have
to do now
so another fun thing I used to do uh I'm
too old and tired and and crickety for
this but when I was a kid
um in an elevator because I grew up in
the city so half my life is in elevators
um if the elevator is going up and it's
about to stop
you jump just at that instant right okay
when you do you had the upward motion
that the elevator had
just before it stopped so then when you
come back down you fall a bigger
distance than you otherwise would have
and it feels it feels great it feels
like like you go over the hill you know
in a car yeah yeah or on a roller
coaster yeah yeah if you do it in the
opposite direction
then the elevator is closer to you than
your body thought it would have been and
you end up
getting compressed a little pancaking a
little pancaking right right but it's
fun to do that where you you are in MO
you're in air while the thing you were
attached to changes its speed it's very
cool yeah I like it yeah so so there you
go in case anybody comes up to you and
wonders what's going on yeah why are you
jumping up and down on a plane
you were jumping up and down one clearly
you are drunk two you listen to start
talking
Chuck that's all I got for you on that
one okay all right all right as always I
bid you to keep looking up
[Music]
thank you